annie bonjourbonjour coup d'être avec
nous sur france 24
on a entendu vladimir poutine ont des
buts de journal il en a profité de cette
date du 9 mai pour justifier à nouveau
sa guerre en ukraine en ce qu'il appelle
une opération
spéciale avec toujours la même
rhétorique ce discours c'était avant
tout à destination de l'opinion publique
russe oui puisque c'est vraiment une
fête nationale de la russie en fait
c'était une fête nationale de lurs est
aujourd'hui de la russie et cette année
10 des éléments les plus essentiels de
la propagande de vladimir poutine pour
réunifier pour mobiliser la population
russe c'est pas lui qui a inventé cette
mobilisation en fait depuis brejnev il
ya cette idée que la grande guerre
patriotique comme il l'appelle donc la
victoire de 1945
c'est l'élément essentiel de
mobilisation à l'époque de toutes les
populations de lurs est aujourd'hui de
la russie et en même temps c'est une
façon de réécrire l'histoire sert quand
on ne garde bien sûr il est clair que
les russes ont payé chèrement la
victoire et ils ont participé de façon
très importante jusqu'à berlin à la
victoire sur hitler en même temps les
dirigeants soviétiques et aujourd'hui
vladimir poutine réécrit l'histoire dans
le sens où ils gomment les aspects qui
le gêne en particulier les les crimes
staliniens la façon dont staline a
conduit la guerre les ratages du début
de la guerre et d'autre part il oublie
un selon d'éléments mais voilà il
choisit ce qui l'intéresse pour
mobiliser la population et d'une
certaine façon il ya une propagande
intensive à la télévision des films sur
la guerre puis toujours la même
rhétorique à elle parle de
dénazification et se sert finalement de
cette guerre contre le nazisme en 1945
pour justifier sa guerre actuelle oui
alors l'aller les façons il présente sa
sont assez singulière puisque d'après
lui donc il se préparait une agression
de l'ukraine contre la russie est donc
préventivement il a pu mener cette
opération de guerre en ukraine c'est
assez singulier quand même parce que
voilà il y avait effectivement une arme
et ukrainienne et c'est qu'il ya eu des
discours disant que l'ukraine voulait
reprendre le donbass mais ce n'est pas
eux qui ont attaqué c'est la russie qui
a attaqué le 24 février l'ukraine et
d'autres paillasse est cette image de la
dénazification alors il prend comme
support le fait que il ya effectivement
eu des mouvements des partis politiques
qui ont affiché des symboles néo nazis
en ukraine sauf que ils ont eu quelques
élus et quelques ministres y compris un
certain moment mais en 2014 mais
aujourd'hui il n'y en a plus au
gouvernement ils sont aussi très
marginaux même si certains certaines
idées persiste naturellement mais ils
sont marginaux est donc accusé le
gouvernement actuel de monsieur et dance
kids de d'être des nazis ou des néonazis
art que lui même et est d'origine juive
ans alors que lui même est d'origine
juive c'est absurde et donc mais ça fait
partie de cette rhétorique
keevill quillan un style dans la
population russe est malheureusement la
plupart des russes n'ont pas grand chose
d'autres comme élément d'information sur
la réalité de ce qui se passe ça marche
ça marche
l'information est verrouillée là depuis
le début
de ce conflit depuis le début de cette
offensive le 24 février dernier non
seulement elle est verrouillée mais vous
savez on sait que ceux qui parlent de
guerre ce qui parle d'agression passes
sont passibles de d'années de prison et
y en a qui ont été arrêtés sur cela
alors on ne sait pas en fait exactement
quel est l'état de l'opinion il ya des
sondages mais ils sont invérifiables
parce que bien entendu dans ces
conditions demander à quelqu'un par
téléphone est ce que vous êtes pour ou
contre la politique de la meilleure
poutine il va hésiter à répondre non
je ne suis pas d'accord donc on ne sait
pas ce qu'on sait c'est que les grandes
villes les jeunes s'informent autrement
que par la télévision officielle
les réseaux sociaux etc où on trouve
encore beaucoup de choses en prison
accès donc à une certaine information
après est ce qu'il croit la propagande
officielle il ya des effets de
génération est ce qu'il croit la presse
la propagande officielle ou au contraire
est ce qui s qui se croient aux images
qui peuvent voir sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est difficile à dire pour l'instant ce
qui est clair c'est que une partie
importante de la population adhère à la
propagande officielle en même temps il
ya les morts qui arrivent il ya on ne
sait pas combien il y en a mais
certainement des milliers et céret finir
par se savoir bien entendu ça se sait et
c'est un peu comme ce qui s'était passé
lors de la guerre en tchétchénie la
première sous helsinn ou le lait mais
les mères de soldats et là le retour des
morts aussi à l'époque de la guerre en
afghanistan avait marqué l'opinion et
petit à petit créer un courant de voilà
de critiques sur cette politique qui qui
a déjà eu il ya déjà des effets
absolument terry terrible pour la russie
a les sanctions économiques mais il ya
aussi le la coupure définitive au moins
pour plusieurs générations entre les
russes et les ukrainiens alors qu'il ya
beaucoup de familles qui ont des cousins
de la famille de parts et d'autres
craignent d'ailleurs pendant son
discours il n'a pas une seule fois
prononcé le nom ukraine vladimir poutine
tout à l'heure il n'y a finalement
l'existence de la nation écrit
en tout cas plusieurs plusieurs
idéologues officiel de proches de lui
ont effectivement publié des textes où
ils disent la nation ukrainienne
n'existe pas c'est une fois aussi c'est
une vieille histoire parce que déjà à
l'époque tsariste il y avait l'idée
qu'il y avait un peuple russe à
l'intérieur duquel on avait des
ukrainiens des biélorusses des russes et
au fond tout ça a été et est été mêlé
est donc cette cette idée que c'est un
peuple russe avec à l'intérieur duquel
il y à des ukrainiens qui était tantôt
ils étaient les petits frères il parlait
un dialecte qui était pas tout à fait du
russe qui était voilà c'est une façon
condescendante et
méprisant de de voir l'ukraine qui est
insupportable pour les ukrainiens et ça
c'est une des fautes majeures de la
demi-heure poutine c'est à dire de ne
pas s'être rendu compte lui et son
entourage visiblement que une nation
ukrainienne s'était formé au 20e siècle
est ce qui explique aussi la résistance
à la faire face l'armée russe elle ne
s'y attendait pas elle ne s'y attendait
pas ce qui est une erreur stratégique
majeure et or
les gens qu'ils étudiaient l'ukraine qui
allait en ukraine voyait bien que depuis
des décennies en fait ce peuple
ukrainien a consolidé son existence et
former une nation dans les frontières
qui effectivement lui ont été légués par
le système soviétique et ça c'est très
importantes comme facteur de résistance
est aujourd'hui encore plus avec un un
président extrêmement alors qui sait
manier habilement la propagande et mekki
un chef de guerre qui étonne tout le
monde est qui qui sommes aussi certes de
d'éléments mobilisateur et fondateur
pour cette nouvelle nation ukrainienne
qui malheureusement se consolide dans la
guerre merci beaucoup jean radvanyi
d'avoir été notre invité sur